[Music]  Selena Gomez suffers a wardrobe  malfunction in LA I think people are  going to be a little surprised the hands  to myself singer stepped out for a day  of press Thursday to promote her latest  single when she accidentally flashed a  little more side boob than expected  Selena opted for this chic ensemble a  white Flair top grey capris statement  belt paired with white pumps but at one  point she suffered a nip slip in the  revealing top from the side view while  in NYC the pop star wowed us with  several stunning looks prior to her  wardrobe oops the 24 year old wore a  cute LBD as she took a trip to her old  stomping grounds at Radio Disney Studios  so this is actually where I got my first  job ever  this building I had to check in there  and then I would have stairs to get my  first job ever so it's so cool to be  back here  [Music]